各位朋友,大家好,我是期货球谋。
最近跟几个朋友一起在探讨这个期货短线交易系统。
我自己也对于我自己这几年做的这个短线交易系统也做了一个总结。
因为一个朋友的要求呢,就希望我能够做成视频,然后发给他。
那么借这个机会呢,我就也跟大家做一个分享吧。
其实分享的内容不会太别长,虽然我分成了五个小节来介绍,
但是内容不会特别多,可能加起来的时间可能也就是30到一个小时之间吧。
那么第一节的内容的话,我可能会先简单的介绍一下我这个期货交易系统的一个框架。
那么其实这个框架呢,就是我后面要介绍我这个具体系统的一个具体内容的一个铺垫。
对于交易系统的重要性,基本上,只要是做交易的都会认识到这个系统的一个重要性。
那么对于我个人来讲的话,我的交易系统呢,它在两个方面,其实关键的重要。
第一点呢,就是振生,第二点就是利命。所谓振生是什么意思呢?
因为我周边的朋友呢,经常说我做期货交易是在赌博。
所以呢,为什么有时候呢,女士要跟他们做解释。
那么有一些聪明的朋友呢,他可能就不会去做解释,
因为没必要解释不同行业,对于不同的理解不一样。
所以呢,很多人会选择去避开谈论这个期货交易。
当对于我来讲,我觉得这个是一个很很正规的一个行业。
那么期货交易也是一个很正规的职业。
所以我有必要跟他们解释清楚什么是期货交易。
那么期货交易呢,它并非是赌博,而我们作为期货交易者也并非是赌博。
那么我的主要理由呢,是在于我们这个期货交易是有一有剧的。
那么这个一跟剧,它来这里哪里?
那么主要来这里我们这个交易系统,它为什么会让你开餐,
为什么会让你平产,为什么要做这个交易?
那么这都来源于你的交易系统。
第二个,利命。利什么命?
这个是换句话说,就是你要实现什么的一个目标。
对于我们期货人来讲,我们的最终目标当然是实现这个财富自由。
那么实现财富自由,我们靠的是什么呢?
我们靠的是我们自己的实力。
当然运气如果好的话,那么你可能在实现这个最终的目标,
可能会走得比较顺畅一点点,
但多数人的运气不可能是一直都能存在的。
所以说,靠运气我可能一时能够获得一个好的目标,
但是我们可能也会凭实力的输回去。
所以说,什么是实力?
实力就是保证我们能够在这个追求目标的同时呢,
能够保证我们目标能够去实现。
所以说我们的交易系统,其实帮助我们去振生和利命。
那么至于这个交易系统的一个框架,
我把我自己的交易系统呢,就总结归纳成两个指系统。
第一个指系统就是这个开屏昌信号系统,
第二个系统就是人性管理系统。
那么开屏昌信号系统呢,
是我这个交易系统的一个核心,
人性管理系统只是对于我前一个指系统的一种强化。
核心的问题呢,就是在于我们做交易呢,
我们要搞清楚我为什么要开昌,我为什么要屏昌,
或者核四开昌,核四屏昌,
如果这个都搞不清楚的话,
那你做交易,那基本上就很难做,
甚至说你可以直接放弃了。
那么我们第一步知道怎么开昌,怎么屏昌,
那么我们接下来有解决的问题呢,
就是我能不能按照我的信号去做到,
去执行,那么这个就是我们人性管理系统的内容了。
我们任何一个交易系统呢,
都是来源于我们的基本面分析,
或者是技术面分析,
当然这两个基本的逻辑呢,
它有它的理论基础,
我们基本面分析所做的基本上,
就是一个公球关系分析,
它的核心就是对于公球,
均含之间的一个状况变化,
情况做的一个分析和预设,
当然可能中间会有一些变量,
比如像库存啊,对吧,
那么这个可能是影响公球的一个中间变量,
当然它最终的本质还是到公球上,
我们技术分析呢,
多数人,
现在可能用的比较多了,
就是这个K线和K线形态,
均线,趋势线,还有不零通道线,
等等一些技术性的一代指标,
这里的话就是必须跟大家提个醒,
至于我们散户,
尤其是这个新手,
我个人坚决的建议,
多研究这个技术分析,
因为呢,基本面分析要取得成功,
其实是很难的,
因为我们多数的人是无法准确的把握到及时的信息和数据,
因为这些数据的一个获取呢,
它可能需要付出很大很大的成本,
比如包括我们就是去实地调研,
那么你这个出差啊,
数据获取的一些样本的一个成本啊,
那么这个是多数人都做不到的,
所以说,我们作为少后我们的地步呢,
应该考虑的是如何从技术上去建立我们的交易系统,
而不是说基本面上去建立,
如果是在技术分析上,
你能建立出你的一个系统,
在慢慢的慢慢的去了解这个基本面,
那么对于你技术分析所建立的系统内,
它是一个很好的补充,
所以说,
我们作为少后我们的起点是如何去做技术分析,
如何用技术分析去建立我们的交易系统,
这是我们作为少后,尤其是新手,
在接触这个期货交易的时候,
所要考虑的一个首要问题,
那么这些各的内容呢就比较简单,
下几个呢,
会跟大家做这个五分钟短信交易系统的一个主要内容的分享。